good afternoon
I'm Gerald James acting chair of
african-american studies it's my great
pleasure to welcome you to the seventh
Henry Louis Gates Jr lecture made
possible by the generous gift of Daniel
and Joanna s Rose now turns out this is
also the 50th anniversary year of
african-american studies at Yale
[Applause]
and partly because of that my thoughts
turned to the year 1980 which will
become obvious as to why shortly that
decade the 80s would witness a
remarkable flowering of afro-american
studies at Yale coming through for
teaching soldiers lasting at least a
year would be Nobel laureate Sir William
Arthur Lewis future Nobel laureate
woolly snow iike Cornel West bell hooks
The Economist Donald Harris now best
known for being the father of Carla
Harris Alice Walker Bucheon Machida just
the name a few three senior professors
John Blasingame in history Robert Ferris
Thompson in the history of art and
Charles T Davis professor of English
chair and dare I whisper master of what
was Calhoun College had assembled
assembled a young cohort of assistant
professors who were stirring things up
at Yale and across the nation
Robert Steptoe had just published his
pioneering critical study of
afro-american narrative from behind the
veil
Sylvia Boone who would become Yale's
first tenured african-american woman was
working on radiance from the waters
ideals of feminine beauty in Mende
culture the Cambridge England trained
philosopher Anthony Appiah was already
around he was the baby in the group
formulating philosophies of race and
culture that would become his
influential book in my father's house
Africa in the philosophy of culture the
intellectual excitement of this period
and interacting in this rio5 company
enticed me away from thinking about
micro economic theory it's fun for some
of us to work on what became my first
book branches without roots genesis of
the black working class in the American
South
I knew skip gates was formulating his
revolutionary interpretation of
african-american literature that would
become the signifying monkey what I
didn't know was that in a mere few
months I would actually be in West
Virginia riding down a bumpy godforsaken
back road in pitch blackness searching
for a cabin back over behind his third
cousins Aunt Bessie and Uncle Joe's
place because cousin had heard there was
this really old and I do mean really
really old black man who knew so many
signifying monkey rhymes he surely must
know some skip had never heard that was
the setting the first decade of black
baby boomers who disrupted campuses all
over America were in the house of Yale
and dedicated to continuing their
traditions we argued and planned on
almost a daily basis what should black
studies be doing what should it look
like then that year Charles Davis made a
young English scholar studying women's
slave narratives and decided to throw
her into this bubbling academic mix so
he invited hazel kirby to visit Yale as
a special
graduate student and did she turn out to
be special
this brilliant vivacious young woman
showed up looking about she must have
been reminded of what it is said that
the English said was wrong with American
soldiers stationed there during World
War two they're overpaid oversexed and
over here for she soon was telling us in
word and deed we were two male centric
two American Century and just a bit too
much in ourselves first came the Empire
Strikes Back race and racism in 70s
Britain a collaboration book by several
young scholars like Paul Gilroy that
fired the first salvo in an awakening of
black Atlantic diasporic studies seminal
essays on women's classic blues singers
and black feminist theory paved the way
for reconstructing womanhood the
emergence of the afro-american woman
novelists which still inspires legions
of scholars today in 1998 race men the
body and soul of race nation and manhood
taught the rest of the world what she'd
been teaching us for two decades her
first coming her forthcoming book
Imperial intimacy's a tale of two
islands will be published this fall
by 1989 Yale struck gold
enticing hazel to return for good thus
she was here in the early 90s to help
design the combined doctoral program in
african-american studies that now
partners with about a dozen Yale
departments and programs
she was chair of the program when it
achieved departmental status in 2000
among her many honors and achievements
she has recently been named a fellow of
the Royal Society of the Arts I cannot
think of anyone more suitable to deliver
african-american studies keynote lecture
during its 50th anniversary year so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome my
longtime friend and colleague the
Charles C and Dorothea s Dilli professor
of African American and American Studies
hazel V
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much everyone for
for coming thank you for such a warm
welcome it's it's an honor to be
delivering the gates lecture I'm sorry
that skip is down with a really bad cold
but he sends his love to everybody and
he's sorry he can't be here to join us
my father Carl cobby grew up in Kingston
Jamaica in what he characterized as
difficult times a phrase he did not
explain now as a child I had no
reference point for what he meant by
difficult or even when those times had
been because in our house
the usual reference point for the past
was the Second World War which was
summoned into being with such animation
and emotion that I felt I had lived it
too my father told me little about
Jamaica It was as if he had been born an
airman in the Royal Air Force and I do
not know when hearing my father utter
the words difficult times prompted me to
see him as a man who had his own history
a life before the war and I was unsure
if I actually wanted to hear my father
explain how difficult those times had
been I feared the anguish that might
escape through the crack that I could
often hear in his voice so for many
years difficult times was a phrase
sufficient unto itself
utter disclosure difficult times
indicated not only that no more needed
to be said but the phrase also
constituted a warning to me that on no
condition was his curious daughter to
pursue the subject a preliminary intake
of breath
a hint that a question was forming would
produce a withering glare and curiosity
would die in my throat for a black girl
and a young black woman who spent so
much of her life in libraries to remain
unaware of the historical conditions
that shaped the man her father was to
become is shocking my ignorance was
hidden under a superficial veneer of
what I thought I knew of Jamaica from
reading from listening to the music of
Robert Nesta Marley and from inhaling
the vibrant if precarious black culture
of the UK which was shaped as much by
cultural forms coming from North America
as from the Caribbean so perhaps it was
a sort of willful blindness a blindness
shared with others of my generation who
focused our political and intellectual
energies on the demand to be regarded as
black Britons as black citizens while
relegating to the back of our minds how
much information about our colonial past
our Caribbean parents deliberately
withheld from us I acknowledged
eventually how little I really knew how
much I needed to unravel to make sense
of difficult times to create even a
partial portrait of my father's life in
Jamaica and his passage into war my
father's story emerged gradually
in fragments and I had to teach myself
to listen not only to his words but also
through his silences I saw the word
Jamaica pass across the television
screens superimposed on the bodies of
women on white sand beaches turquoise
seas palm trees and bushes covered in
the most brilliant red flowers I had
ever seen and I turned to look at him I
saw actors in 19th century plantation
dress beckoning promising a return to
the island as it used to be a visual
realization of the modern form of
indenture and indebtedness produced by
tourism walking together down Croydon
High Street my father stops and stares
at advertising images for Jamaica
reproduced on large posters in the
windows of the travel agents he
considers the information about British
Airways British overseas Airways flights
to Kingston and my father begins to talk
at home
he rummages around in his wardrobe finds
a red shoebox
and carries it to me the corners are
torn and the box held together with
rubber bands but from the way he holds
it I know that it is not just fragile
but precious on the torn lid the gold
lettering has faded so I cannot read the
name of the shop but I can't
barely make out the word Kingston inside
our postcards letters and photographs
inside is Jamaica unfamiliar names fall
from his lips
now I anticipated that my father would
confirm the romance of landscape and
beautiful bodies used to tantalize and
entice tourists I was wrong
at first I saw my father's postcards
through the eyes of a young black woman
who had grown up in Europe I saw through
the eyes of the Metropole London had
bestowed on me an imperial gaze the gaze
of a potential tourist who only saw
scenes of lush vegetation and the luxury
of abundance listening closely though I
heard my father's memories as a critical
commentary on what I saw and only then
did I grasp his becoming he gave me the
gift of a counter history which revealed
the enormous distance from and the
dissonance between the advertising
campaigns and what my father knew of
Jamaica as it used to be I came to
understand the images as both a backdrop
and a stage for a drama of contradiction
through the stories of my father I
became more than a daughter of a
Jamaican I became both historian and
colonial subject I learnt what it meant
to live in Jamaica as a crown colony
under the rule of the Colonial Office
that was four thousand six hundred and
eighty miles away I learnt about massive
unemployment and of starvation wages
paid to those who had jobs I learned of
the complete and utter immiseration of a
population and I learnt about the hunger
marches and the protests across the
British West Indies of the 1930s now I
did not immediately place my father or
his family among those who were hungry
but slowly I recognized that I had a
relation to these starving people they
were my family two aunts and uncles
grandparents great uncles and aunts
cousins I encountered the particular
social economic and political conditions
in Jamaica in the context of this unrest
and I confronted colonialism in the
aftermath of enslavement I was a
daughter beginning to understand her
father many decades later on Father's
Day in June 2013
I was holding my father's thin cold
hands between mine in a village outside
of the city of York we were alone a
father and a daughter together in one of
the few rooms of his residential care
home that was without a television and
we relished a rare moment of quiet away
from the main rooms which despite their
cheerful and sunny
aspect felt like warehouses for aged and
decaying bodies rooms in which I
experienced a constriction in my chest
we were looking through large windows
onto a lovely garden but all of a sudden
my father's grasp
tightened around my hand and I turned to
look at him startled I must tell you he
said with extraordinary urgency how
terrible how very very terrible it was
as his memories tumbled out we were no
longer in Yorkshire but we were on the
streets of Kingston in May 1938 where
mass protests immediately followed the
burning of cane fields strikes that
began on Titan Lyles Frome estate of
sugar estate and a factory in
Westmoreland had spread to other estates
across the island and onto the banana
and the coal Wars of the Kingston
dockyards where one of my father's
uncle's was a wolf manager a hundred
years after the supposed emancipation
men women and children still lived and
worked under the regimes of power
poverty and punishment that we associate
with enslavement protesting workers at
Frome were shot by the police
the British company Titan aisle garnered
enormous profits during the 30s with the
acquisition of plantations and the
building of a new factory at Frome in
1937 rumours spread across labourers in
the island that Tate & Lyle was going to
increase workers wages when these
expectations were not met bitter
disappointment was followed by
explosions of anger the rallying cry of
the workers was a dollar a day but Tate
Lyle of course preferred to pay generous
dividends to its investors than to
invest in labor the labor that toiled on
starvation wages so I was startled by
the sudden urgency in my father's voice
and I was puzzled by his persistent
tugging at my hand to force me to pay
attention I heard a warning to be
careful an admonition to learn from what
had happened in Jamaica and what it
meant to protest in the streets to
confront political authority directly to
be brutally beaten by the police and the
military I realized that my father no
longer saw the middle-aged daughter in
front of him but actually was addressing
his rebellious young daughter the
daughter who marched and protested in
the streets of London the daughter who
needed to listen to him my father's
memories of riots in Jamaica in 1938
were folded into incident
of rebellion and police brutality in the
UK the first time his daughter faced
Mounted Police
during anti-vietnam protests in front of
the American Embassy in Grosvenor Square
in 1968 times when he was forced to
confront the British racism that he was
very reluctant to acknowledge times when
he was deeply afraid for his daughter
and times when he feared for the future
of black life in Britain he was
simultaneously recalling many marches
and many protests that had occurred
between 1968 and 1981 black protests in
Lewisham and neuen the black people's
day of action in 1981 and of course
rebellion on the streets of the cities
of Bristol Brixton Liverpool and
Manchester I was shaken and disoriented
by how intensely I could feel the fear
radiating from my father as he recalled
all those places and times all I could
do was try to reassure and calm him to
calm myself the crisis my father
experienced in June 2013 replays in my
mind like a film loop and I am unable to
provide any simple explanation for its
eruption perhaps the trigger was the
images of hundreds of riot police in
full battle mode against the g8 summit
protesters in London
that actually had saturated the media in
the days immediately prior to my visit
and the televisions in his home were on
all the time showing these images but
what remains with me most vividly is the
memory of a father issuing a warning to
a young daughter that he is afraid is in
danger while also calling upon me as a
teacher and a mother urging me to pass
on his stories to my students to his
grandson to the next generation in April
2014 three months after the death of my
father I am on a research trip to
Jamaica a taxi driver takes me to 19
Potter's row in Raytown now the driver
who grew up in the City of Kingston
states boldly and somewhat warily that
he's never been to this poverty-stricken
neighborhood before before I left the
hotel I stared at myself in the bathroom
mirror I was trying to steel myself
against grief by fully inhabiting the
dispassionate mode of the scholar but my
attempt to adopt a professional exterior
had little staying power and my facade
crumbled when I stood as a bereaved
daughter rooted to the spot outside the
house where my father was born in 1921 I
was barely aware that my driver had
explained our presence to the young
people gathered on the corner that the
eldest boy peeled off from the group and
as he ran up the steps into the house
said I will ask ask
did he say my sister did he say my
mother the name of the person he went to
fail to find was lust as he turned away
his voice was barely audible above the
sound system at the other end of the
street a young woman came down the steps
to meet the stranger at her front door
Sheila she listened patiently I told her
that my father was born in the house in
1921 and she raised her eyebrows I asked
permission to photograph the outside of
the building which was instantly granted
but it was one of Kingston's very very
hot days the air was heavy and still and
neither she nor I actually wanted to
stand in the full glare of the Sun for
too much longer without entering the
yard I rapidly took two photographs the
young woman was courteous and polite but
I felt impertinent an intruder into the
lives of those who lived there and I
just wanted to vanish if only I could
explain the words if only I could find
the words to explain to her that I'm a
daughter grieving for her father than
I'm overwhelmed by a deluge of his
memories of poverty I started my thanks
but I'm mortified to realize that in my
haste not to be a nuisance I've
neglected to introduce myself properly
or to ask her name I yearn to say more
to her retreating back but then it's too
late and she's already reentered her
home no one seemed discomforted by my
visit but me I felt I behaved like an
entry
imperialistic anthropologist POTUS Rho
which is the street that you see here
lives sorry Potter's row which is this
street actually lies in the shadow of
this very notorious general penitentiary
the maximum security prison covers 11
acres of the south side of the street
for three blocks west and three blocks
south all the way to the water and you
can see the back of the penitentiary
from the palisade O's and from the
Norman manly international airport built
in the 19th century by the British the
prisoner the prison has a very sinister
and daunting aspect as you can see it is
designed to generate or and fear it
resembles both a fortress and the Tower
of London the brick walls are 22 feet
high and 5 feet 6 inches thick with
round watchtowers on each corner in the
corner of the street is a massive tower
with crenellated battlements housing the
main gate the entire outer perimeter is
adorned with razor wire this is the
prison of one of my family's stories the
general penitentiary actually remains to
this day
notorious for the inhuman treatment of
prisoners for the cruelty and brutality
of its systems of discipline and
punishment for its overcrowding for the
gross inadequacy of the new
quality and quantity of its food and for
its unsanitary conditions that to quote
from a report beggar the imagination but
in the 1930s people felt that conditions
were better inside the prison than
outside of it the starving and the
unemployed organized marches to be
admitted to the general penitentiary in
order to be fed we knew someone inside
my father said and I was sent to the
back door of the prison where the guard
would pass out loaves of bread baked in
the prison ovens so many were inside
because of their poverty but as I
listened to my father's stories
I wondered how he managed to avoid
imprisonment in the penitentiary that
cast such a shadow over his birthplace
Carl was raised by his grandmother Marie
Monroe who was left with five children
when her husband Edward George Monroe a
commercial Clarke died in the Kingston
earth quake which struck on January the
14th 1907 just after 3:30 in the
afternoon the commercial and the
residential sections of the city were
utterly destroyed and there were over a
thousand fatalities Edward left for work
that morning and he was never seen again
his body was never recovered the initial
35 seconds of tremors from the massive
9.5 magnitude earthquake toppled
buildings overturned on the buses and
streetcars
and caused fires residents were crushed
buried under rubble and burnt to death
Edward was employed in the business
district where fires could not be
quelled because the fire station had
collapsed white residents fled Kingston
and over 10,000 black and colored
survivors found themselves living on the
racecourse where a tent city was
eventually erected weeks later the
Colonial Office instituted a complex
Imperial accounting system which
revealed the stunning callousness of
Imperial calculation intended to issue
financial assistance only to quote
worthy recipients as a widow with
children marie was entitled to support
but only if she could produce extensive
documentation to prove that she had been
legally married and that her children
were legitimate the British government
demanded that Jamaicans who were
traumatized by the violence of a major
earthquake grieving the loss of partners
parents children and friends whose
dwellings were destroyed along with all
their possessions produce extensive
documentation all district relief
committees were under very strict
instructions to compensate only quote
reputable widows and orphans if Murray
was awarded anything and I doubt it she
would have received a 25 pounds and Uwe
T as long
as she did not remarry so Edwards death
brought both anguish and financial
insecurity as a child my father hungered
not only for food but also for education
and he longed to attend one of Jamaica's
prestigious secondary schools that
prepared the islands elite for entry
into professions and universities in
Europe and North America but their doors
were open only to the wealthy instead he
had to assume increasing responsibility
for his family which included his
grandmother his mother and six younger
siblings when he was still in elementary
school by 1936 he was going to work
every day sweeping out a hardware store
in the evenings he attended Kingston
Technical College when he obtained his
school certificate and passed courses in
bookkeeping he was promoted to the
position of a clerk the average wage for
a clerk was between eight and nine
shillings a week and with this he had to
support his extended family his
diligence was not the only reason that
Carl could be a clerk because having
liked coffee colored skin as opposed to
dark Browns was a prerequisite for the
job in what Stuart Hall has called a
pigment okra see in the 1930s and 40s
only those of the very lightest hue were
employed as shop assistants because they
liked the goods on display in the window
where in the front of the stores
the backrooms merchants employed brown
Jamaicans like Carl manual labor on the
sugar estates are on the dockyards was
overwhelmingly dark-skinned in May 1938
in the wake of the unrest and agitation
against starvation wages on tighten
Lyles whisker estate at firm the Wharf
workers employed by the United Fruit
Company staged a general walkout what
happened at Frome was just a prelude to
rebellion across the island among urban
and rural workers from banana growers in
Portland and st. Mary to field and
factory cane workers to Public Works
Department laborers and militant
ex-servicemen who had been settled on
government grants land grants in
Kingston it was not just Dockers but
waged workers in the private and public
sectors with the exception of shop
assistants and Clark's among whom of
course was my father although they too
were aged workers they actually aspired
to reach the lower rungs of the middle
class the store where Carr worked was on
West Parade which bordered what was then
called Victoria Park an important site
for political meetings and street
auratus and for agitation for increased
wages labor rights and rights to land
ownership for the generation of hope and
for belief in a future my father
described the vast numbers of people
that would gather on Sundays to listen
to the rousing speeches and in May
gatherings increased in frequency
did he just hurry past all this
political activity to take care of his
grandmother or attend an evening class
or did my father overhear a word phrase
a sentence an appeal for justice that
made him hesitate linger and join the
throngs of people unrest and strikes
across the island that continued
throughout the month of May were met by
force in addition to the police there
were six platoons of the Sherwood
Foresters Regiment of the British Army
almost five thousand armed special
constables and two cruisers of the Royal
Navy by May 23rd a general strike was
underway in Kingston kaol would have
gone to work as usual but as strikers
and protesters marched down King Street
toward parade early in the day all the
stores closed
the city was brought to a standstill a
strikes of manual workers and train
drivers erupted throughout the capital
what did my father witness in 1938 that
made him so afraid for the safety of his
daughter marching in London decades
later what memories of these events
still haunted him in the last months of
his life lessons that he wanted his
daughter to know and to pass on on the
first day of the Kingston strike police
beat protesters with their battles by
the next day May 24th
Empire Day a public holiday military
trucks patrolled Kingston and the
police were using bullets that killed
and wounded civilians residents of
Kingston had to face 400 police officers
80 troops 250 special constables and the
Kingston infantry volunteers in cars
neighbourhood a woman and her
nine-year-old son were killed by police
in Matthew Lane both of them just shot
in the head the police clubbed anyone
who gathered around to watch on Hanover
Street a youth was bayonetted in the leg
and on North Street two girls and a man
was shot by military paroles patrols
this violence continued and increased
and on May 25th Kingston shop assistants
and clans joined the strikers the
British government more concerned with
their Imperial adventures on the
continent of Africa and in India
relegated their crown colony of Jamaica
to the status and I quote from records
an imperial backwater
and regarded it as quote a financial
burden poverty and pain were constant
companions in Jamaica decades of
colonial neglect and the starvation
wages and malnutrition inevitably
followed lay not just on the surface of
the skin in the beaded sweat of rebels
but hollowed out the bodies of adults
and children softening bones in flaming
joints penetrating livers spleens
kidneys and hearts attacking lungs and
bowels the effects of colonial neglect
can be seen in the high death rate among
infants and it's also evident in the
diseases that were suffered by many
members of Carl's family Murray's health
deteriorated and she developed
difficulty breathing a doctor
recommended that they move closer to the
water where the sea air might help and
Carl became desperate and searched for
weeks to find somewhere on or near the
seafront that he could afford eventually
moving with his grandmother to twelve
water lane where they shared a house
with other tenants poor working people
always have to work multiple jobs and
Carl for Carl it was no different he was
employed as the caretaker for water lane
in return for the reduct for a reduction
in rent he was responsible for the other
talents for the house for the grounds
and for maintaining its Beach so
becoming caretaker was added to his
full-time job attending evening classes
helping younger siblings with their
schoolwork and nursing his grandmother
I suspect Marie suffered from pulmonary
tuberculosis my father always became
deliberately vague when asked about his
grandmother's symptoms as if he had to
conceal what he knew and felt there was
such a stigma attached to the disease
that he would have been ashamed to admit
to it if it was true now in the
Metropole the 1911 national insurance
Act and the public health acts of 1921
and 1936 actually laid the groundwork
for legislation that would provide a
National Health Service after World War
two and in the UK there was a complex
network of sanatoria hospitals
dispensaries and medical specialists
devoted to the free treatment of
tuberculosis that was built through
direct state intervention in Jamaica
though the British state abdicated
responsibility colonial subjects had to
pay a fee for each use of the
underfunded and frequently inadequate
medical services there was a system of
medical relief tickets for subjects
earning less than twelve shillings a
week but to be eligible one had to prove
that you were on the poor per roll or
deemed worthy by a parochial board
responsible for the distribution of
tickets and in addition to that a
separate ticket had to be obtained for
each and every medical visit the ticket
system became the most criticized aspect
of the colony's medical services Carl
was able to ease the final days weeks
and months of Murray's life but he could
not prevent her death on the 6th of May
in 1941
my father's stories and memories
revealed the emergence of a man whose
sense of self coalesced around the
concept of dignity a dignity maintained
in relation to conditions of personhood
deportment and employment
wearing shirts with a collar and a tie a
suit polished shoes working in a clean
and orderly environment being trusted to
tend to the accounts of a business
becoming a person who could gain and
retain respect in the face of desperate
poverty my father adopted the clerical
garb and manners of accountancy as a
counterweight to the terrible conditions
his clothes were part of keeping it
together a demonstration of restraint
and dignity as he buttoned his collar
and knotted his tie my father swallowed
the bile of poverty and kept in check
the emotions that surged when he was
being treated as less than human the
immediate effect of the outbreak of war
in September 1939 was that the prices of
food firewood kerosene men's trousers
boots and imported cloth soared although
no one escaped the effect of rampant
inflation this was a disaster
for the poor who were barely surviving
even before the price increases by 1942
Jamaica was in a dire economic crisis
with massive unemployment no fuel was
being delivered because German u-boats
were operating throughout the Caribbean
destroying shipping and oil storage
tanks crime in Kingston rose
dramatically one ironic comment on the
state of wartime Jamaica was made by
street gangs
who chose to operate under the name of
RAF conjuring the image of the Royal Air
Force but actually meaning Rob and free
recruitment for the Royal Air Force
began in Jamaica in April of 1942 and my
father was always proud to say that he
was among the first to volunteer after a
series of rigorous and medical
educational tests Carr was accepted into
the RAF to train as aircrew he made a
special point of saying that he was
issued with two sets of tropical uniform
I never understood the significance of
this remark until I discovered how
extremely expensive clothes had become
in wartime Jamaica car left the island
on June 18th 1943 unaware that he would
never live there again it was a full
week journey the first leg of which was
on a Canadian steamship to New York and
then via Canadian Pacific rail to
Moncton New Brunswick it was not at home
but at school that the child who was to
become this Airman's daughter was told
that Britain in 1940 stood alone facing
invasion after the fall of Europe to
Hitler's armies and the evacuation of
the British Expeditionary Force from
Dunkirk in school many of the speeches
of Winston Churchill were read out loud
by the teachers and poetic phrases
became ingrained in the minds of the
pupils who in turn were forced to recite
and now it has come to us to stand alone
in the breach and face the worst that
the tyrants might
enmity can do we are fighting by
ourselves alone but we are not fighting
for ourselves alone Churchill's words
were used as a pedagogical entre to
instill British character the preeminent
qualities of which we were told were
manifest during the war his phrases and
his cadence were resonant with
Shakespearean language meter and imagery
particularly the speeches of Henry the
fifth which we were also taught to
recite the question that dogged me as a
schoolgirl was how the peculiarities of
English character evident during World
War two when they stood alone related to
the framed portrait of my father in his
RAF uniform which stood on our piano
even if he could be characterized as a
good yeoman his limbs were not made in
England I was unable to solve the
contradiction when only a girl but it
was my first lesson in historical
amnesia it was not for many years that I
understood that a might of the British
Empire and its powerful Imperial economy
rendered the meaning of standing alone
and absurd if efficacious claim Britain
mobilised vast resources including
people from around the globe and
assembled them into one of the most for
machines the planet has ever seen the
RAF smore time expansion was embodied in
the British Commonwealth air training
plan the most ambitious aviation
training programme in history my
father's amazement was evident in his
voice when he described arriving
arriving in Moncton as like a holiday
what he remembered most vividly was the
food lots of excellent meals and as much
as one could devour my father was no
longer hungry
Carl began the next stage of his journey
in Halifax Nova Scotia where he and
other RAF recruits from the Caribbean
joined a large North Atlantic convoy
consisting of cargo vessels protected by
battleships and frigates recruits were
packed for to a bunk on a troop ship it
was like pushing animals together
because they really have the ships all
cramped to make sure they got as many as
they put to fight for England it was in
this convoy that Carl entered the Battle
of and for the Atlantic I was only able
to extract very thin threads of memory
from my father which easily became
tangled and only gradually could I
loosen them actually in the archive of
the Admiralty records where the calculus
of war and the brutal reasonings of
expendability became evident in his
usual restrained and very understated
manner my father described his journey
across the Atlantic as being quote more
eventful than life at Moncton because
the convoy was
attacked by German submarines sound
travels underwater much faster than
through the air so I realized that he
and the other recruits lying in the
bowels of the ship probably seasick
would have heard the explosions before
the crew on the deck shock waves would
have rocked the ship was this the time
and place I wondered when car began to
feel fear when the feeling of adventure
the holiday ended and war began my
father told me he did not know until he
landed in the UK that two of the ships
in the convoy were lost in the attack
but he never spoke about what happened
to the crew aboard those ships such
silences distance myself from disaster
and from danger as does the language of
war it was ships that were lost not
human beings
my father's careful word choice rendered
invisible the fact that 186 people died
and dozens were wounded when the or can
flying under the flag of Poland was
torpedoed and sank within five minutes
on October the eighth and a cargo vessel
the u.s. York Mar was torpedoed and sank
the following day what Kyle did not know
what he could not have known what none
of them who made that journey knew or
were ever to know was that their convoy
SC 143 was used as bait in the battle
for the control of the North Atlantic
the British enigma cipher machine had
broken the German codes and the Western
Approaches command knew that rossbach a
wolf pack of
new boats was lying in wait for SC 143
so they seize the opportunity to attack
it the convoy was reinforced with four
destroyers including the Orkin which
sank and the entire convoy was sent
directly towards Ross back but it was
not only these calculations of
expendability that I had to discover in
the archives
I knew that my father's training in the
RAF involved not only the acquisition of
skills that he described in detail
flying wireless telegraphy military
drills but that there were multiple
realities and equations of war that he
did not pass on he was silent about his
role in a war machine that was
determined to exercise its maximum
destructive capacity no longer a clerk
in the backroom of tailors notion and
hardware and furniture dealer whose
horizons were confined by the columns of
account books and the endless battles to
fend off despair and destitution for his
family Karl mapped a space for his
existence that must have appeared vast
with possibility the wages and apparent
benefits of the war machine are a denial
of its fundamental inhumanity if my
father was scarred by what he saw of the
violence of the Imperial state
perpetrated against people just like him
on the streets of Kingston if he found
such violence terrible he had nothing to
say
about the Allied policy of massacre by
aerial bombardment that was perpetrated
by the RAF on German cities my father
and his crew served in Bomber Command
twentieth squadron when they were flying
information among a fleet of advancing
bombers I wonder if my father and his
crew ever saw themselves as WG Seybold
has described as teeming messengers of
death striking like the apocalypse
did they ever attempt to account for the
destruction that they unleashed or
recognize that the war in the air was
pure and undisguised when I first heard
about Bomber Command and about Essen
described by my father as an industrial
town I imagined the destruction of
factories and machinery I was unable to
comprehend the full horror the
deliberate annihilation of people their
dwellings their history and their
natural environment I do not know what
my father thought that he and his crew
and his squadron left behind them in
Essen after they had dropped their bombs
when my father recounted his most
difficult and painful experience of the
war it was the breakup of his crew and
their demobilization I will always
remember his words after spending so
much time together and sharing various
experiences as one a very strong bond
developed and breaking off this bond
suddenly
was far from being easy he treasured
being as one and for him for the first
time in his life that meant being
regarded as an absolute equal my father
was mistaken to think that such
camaraderie once forged would last
forever because what he was to face in
post-war Britain were times more
difficult than he could possibly have
imagined thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]